did you watch bill maher's uh uh
message he gave li i think you sent it
did you send it to me yes sir you sent
it to me and the premise behind it was
what he was asking he said he said you
know we're looking at statistics about
the lgbtq community
tom have you seen this or no
recently no have you have you seen that
catalina
everybody's got to watch it go ahead no
essentially the premise is
america's getting gayer and gayer so he
shows statistic about about seven months
ago we had gad saddam right
uh who i think he's coming back on the
podcast yeah so we had him on and in the
middle of the podcast i asked him a
question i said do you think the media
is increasing the media and tv shows do
they have any influence over increasing
uh the lgbtq community in america says i
don't think it has any influence so
while we're talking i'm googling to see
the increasing population of
you know gays and lesbians and you see
how 30 years ago it's one percent and
it's increased to five percent
but then bill maher went full blown on
this video i i wish we could play it
where he says it started off with this
many percent then it went to five
percent then it went to this and it says
gen z
uh uh fifty percent of gen z or some big
number right twenty percent twenty
percent basically yeah sees themselves
as part of the lgbtq community and it
says at this pace folks in the next 10
20 years we're all going to be gay right
that's pretty much what bill maher was
talking about but here's the point
here's a point
that right there the statistic with what
bill maher talked about gets me to think
about
something i was in the military we had
people who were gays and lesbians in the
military okay in high school you know we
had folks who were part of a lgbt you
know lg community and we had some guys
like that guy's problem you know you
kind of knew about it right
but for it to increase the way it is
that doesn't mean a lot of these people
that are becoming lesbians and gays were
born lesbian i wonder how much of it is
grooming i wonder how much of it is
recruiting i wonder how much of it is
converting i wonder how much of it is i
don't have a data in my picture i don't
have a strong father figure i don't have
a strong leader in my house you know
maybe you know like the famous question
which is what
how do you know you're not gay you're
not gonna know unless if you kiss
somebody how do you know you're not
lesbian you're not gonna know something
it's like maybe i am maybe oh my god i'm
not getting more attention not every
girls are not interested in me or guys
are not interested in me but she's
interested in me and this is kind of
cool so the reason why i brought this up
right off the bat is to say
you don't see statistics showing
the increased percentage of men has
increased you know by 40 in the last 20
years we don't see stats like that
you don't see the increase in women has
increased the last 20 30 40 years why
because
it's naturally we don't think about that
then how if it's scientific how is the
lgbtq community keep increasing
and we're trusting kids to go to public
schools
to be doctor indoctrinated in this
mindset
and then you're having people like aoc
whose concept is being bought by
students because maybe teachers are
grooming and shaping their mindset this
this is this is a little bit of
recruitment going on what do you think
about this you're the one that's closer
to it so happy that you brought this up
because this has been coming up a lot on
the campaign trail
two points here i think number one when
you talk about teachers a long time ago
my mom was a teacher for 30 years right
those teachers even if they were liberal
they didn't push their ideologies to
their kids maybe from an economic you
know bad man rich things like that in
the college
ages but particularly for the younger
generations they still wanted the
star-spangled banner a lot of their dads
had fought in world war ii they were
still americans
somebody figured out along the way that
the culture war instead of economics is
the culture war is the way to change the
hearts and minds and to make kids
liberal i talk to parents every single
day on the campaign trail i talk to kids
every day on the campaign trail i just
spoke with a 13 year old last week who
said that she was
confused for an entire year of what her
gender was because in school her
teachers the millennials that were
these useful idiots i'll call them that
that don't even understand what they're
talking about half the time to the kids
these millennial teachers are pushing
the the pride flags in schools they have
groups that you're allowed to join these
lgbtq whatever groups and
and you're not allowed to join any other
groups you should prob they encourage
people to join these groups that and
then it's just so it's surrounded
it's they're constantly surrounded by it
and then they get confused and then it's
a cool thing for their friends to do and
it becomes a fad she was confused for a
year because it was in her environment
yeah that so so is there straight groups
is there straight groups that you join
like can i go join a straight group no
that's considered hateful so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]